uh
yeah
so you
me personally
claim that I'm the best or most
wonderful person in the world no
uh yeah
right I do not look like Putin that's
true
no yeah
um
but there have been several moments in
life when I went to defend both my own
wealth and democracy
foreign bare-handed against weapons
and then another moment uh came in 2003
again
I was doing fine believe me
yeah
in the same way very comfortably
foreign foreign
belief that my country could be made
better
yeah we shall Assurance
so I went and spoke out and I lost and I
paid with 10 years of my life
ah
yes
and now you know I'm here I'm free and I
continue fighting
I think
foreign
could I just said something I think the
charge of being an opportunity is an
opportunist would be absolutely
Justified if he had only started to
enunciate his opposition to Putin after
he'd fallen out with Putin
but he was already doing it back in 2000
2003
he was standing up for the values of
liberal democracy and freedom and that
was what got him in trouble with Putin
his big confrontation with Putin was in
February 2003 and he was arrested in
October and between February and October
he was endlessly being warned by people
in the Kremlin
that you need to get out now
so he had those months where he said to
the other people in ucos
you don't need to be part of this you go
if you want to go
but he didn't he took a conscious
decision to stay in Russia knowing that
he would be on the receiving end of some
rough Justice from Putin he may not have
known that he was going to spend 10
years in a prison but he knew he was
going to go to jail so he had that
opportunity to get out he could have
taken enough money with him to have a
very nice lifestyle in the west but he
didn't
he stayed
and the reason he stayed was because he
genuinely believed in the values that he
was fighting for so I think there is a
certain amount of idealism in doing that
and he certainly paid for it so the
charge of opportunism I don't think is a
fair one I mean I can see why you asked
the question but I really don't think
it's fair to say that so if I had to say
idealist or opportunist I'd say idealist